this
is a time of conquest the age
of vikings
in assassin's creed valhalla you play as
avor
the fierce viking warchief of the raven
clan
evil and their kin have forged into
england to settle the new frontiers
but these are dangerous times and each
new landscape contains untold perils
and mysteries to uncover
your saga begins with a simple need
for a home your viking settlement
is the beating heart of your adventure
and is the intersecting point from many
of valhalla's interwoven storylines
[Music]
here you'll get familiar with your clan
and begin your journey through england
at the alliance map you'll meet ranvi
the clan's key intel gatherer
and plan your first moves avor
sigurd i give you england and its four
kingdoms
mercia east anglia northumbria
and wessex by forging alliances with
different territories
the ravenclan will expand their
influence allowing you to grow your
settlement
and open a wealth of new narrative arcs
missions
activities and ways to experience the
game world
let's go it's time to capture a kingdom
each of england's kingdoms have many
stories to uncover
with their own unique plot lines casts
of characters
and challenges to overcome are you
sigurds draenger avor
if you keep that up stay in the floors
including assassinating targets forging
allies
and assaulting rivals in large scale
battles
these story arcs explore the themes of
honor
glory leadership and choice that are
central to evil's journey
and your pivotal choices will leave long
lasting impacts across the kingdoms
three men three possible futures
who will serve us best in a time of true
need
viking warfare is visceral and brutal
and there are many powerful rivals and
enemy types that will stand in your way
thankfully avor is equipped with a
diverse set of combat skills
including brute strength charging
maneuvers close quarters melee attacks
and explosive two-handed finishes while
range abilities
like man's best friend and poison powder
trap
allow you to flank and interrupt your
foes from a distance
your skills are upgraded through a
progression system which allows you to
unlock perks and abilities
to suit your style of play special
abilities
are found in books of knowledge hidden
throughout the world
and have their own upgrade tears that
improve their power and effectiveness
as you forge deeper on your journey your
explorations will reward you with exotic
gear from the far
corners of the world further unlocking
combat options
and dual wield combinations including
the legendary
excalibur
choice is central to valhalla's player
experience
and that begins with avor at the start
of your adventure
you'll have the opportunity to choose
avor's gender
and you can seamlessly swap between male
and female avor
at any time during your story and so i
race my horn
to the raven clan the best of friends
and fighters
after a victory you return home with
resources pillaged from your conquests
using them to expand your settlement
with structures and upgrades
there's a wide variety of structures to
build each with their own unique
gameplay systems and perks
the barracks allow you to elect a yomvi
king which is a powerful viking
lieutenant
and build a custom crew of raiders to
ride with which are shared with your
friends online
gunner the blacksmith enhances weapons
and gear
and at the tattooist you'll customize
avor's look
at the shipyard goodrun and goodman will
customize
and improve your longship and in the
hidden ones bureau
you will work from the shadows
embroiling yourself in a mysterious
conflict
with the order of the ancients
we have work to do starting in the
cities of england
our task will not be an easy one
these are just a few examples and
there's plenty more fun to be had around
your settlement
drink your weight in ale play a game of
orlog
or throw a massive viking feast however
growth comes with its own set of dangers
and your settlement will become the
target of new enemy factions
a septic rot has overtaken this shire
valhalla's world is built for a
wandering spirit
you'll uncover deeper layers to avoid
story
in a set of dramatic and intimate
narrative through lines
i lost my parents when i was nine
winters along
without cigarette i would have
there is always one unbreakable bond
yes player choice is woven through every
facet of the game experience
and as you continue to explore you'll
uncover
new stories and epiphanies in the most
unlikely places
drink if you seek true
understanding but this world is just the
beginning
balka the clan seer will unlock your
senses
allowing you to leap beyond to asgard
the legendary realm of norse myth
from norway to england to new worlds
assassin's creed valhalla allows you to
experience your own
elemental viking saga the thrill
of discovery the glory of victory
and the light of kinship a journey
beyond kingdoms and into the soul
of a warrior
[Music]
assassin's creed valhalla available
november 10th